there was this other topic that I kind
of wanted to bring up that was from once
again it was from jock alive and and
there was a young woman and again this
this goes to the kind of variety of
different people that were coming uncle
lives were all over the place so this
this young woman asked a question that
was kind of like how do you pan and I
can't when you're at the live events
there's light shining in your eyes so
you're not really a hundred percent sure
you don't get it it's not like you're
not seeing the person face to face so
I'm kind of looking out into the light
I'm seeing this frame of a young woman
and she asked something along the lines
of you know how do you handle when
there's people that are trying to pull
you down and and and you know pick you
apart hmm
and I said well what do you do and she's
like I'm in school and I said what
school and she's in high school and I
said what grade and she said I'm a
freshman and I said okay so you're
getting bullied right because
essentially that's what that's what she
was saying right I'm getting poked at
picked on I got people trying to drag me
down what you know what that's called
that's called bullying I said so you're
getting bullied and she said yes getting
bullied so I said I said you know I
thought about it for a second I said
well I've got some bad news and I've got
some good news and I'm gonna start with
the bad news the bad news is that people
can be mean and they can be mean for a
variety of reasons they can be mean
because they're insecure they can be
mean because they're bullied themselves
they can be mean because they're unhappy
they can be mean because they're scared
to be vulnerable so they put up that
front they might be suffering and
jealous and have no self-esteem
it's
the way some people are and there's some
people that are just evil that get joy
out of putting other people down so
there's all those kind of people exist
and they especially exist inside of
immature people in high school so that's
the bad news
and then I said but the good news is
high school is not life and when I said
that it was actually funny when I said
that like people started clapping
because everyone in that room knew that
it was true and that reminded me of
another conversation that I've been
having with people lately about about
some about ecosystems something I've
called eco systems so little ecosystems
in the world that people get caught up
in and they get caught trying to get to
the top hierarchy of some little
ecosystem somewhere and look I get it
you know I get it Jordan Jordan Peterson
was trying to ascend the top of our
dominance hierarchy be the best you can
I totally get that mm-hmm absolutely
but we there's there can be a problem
with this from multiple angles the world
is filled with these little ecosystems
and high school is one of them remember
the little high school ecosystem there's
someone that's popular there's someone
that's you know there's all these little
feet there's this ecosystem there and
high school this is something you know
you you look at a high school kid and
you you try and explain to them that
once you left high school no one really
cares right correct if you care about it
deeply you're actually uncle Rico right
you know that's running around saying
when I was in high school this and when
I was in high school that but here's the
problem and this is one of the reasons
when I wrote way the warrior kid
one one of the things that triggered me
to write it was you know here I was at
work
war going on being real legitimate crazy
problems and and dynasties and dynamics
to figure out like things are going on
and I come home and like my one of my
kids would be sad that they got called
the name mm-hmm or sad that they got a
low grade on a test or whatever and I
would be thinking like I I had a moment
of clarity where I thought I can't
believe they're I can't believe they're
sad about this who cares
and then I realized oh yeah idiot jock
oh yeah that thing that's going on in
their world is their whole world
it's the Eco to see it's their entire
their entire world is in that one
ecosystem so it's hard for people to
realize that their ecosystem that
they're in is not the whole world it's
the same thing with when you start going
to college and I've got two kids in
college now you know this whole
ecosystem around first getting into
college and once you get to college with
you know where you're gonna get your MBA
where you're doing your internship
there's this whole thing right and once
again if you step outside that ecosystem
into just the normal world no one
actually cares about where you got your
degree yeah not no one because there's a
little peep there's a group of people
inside that ecosystem that they they go
where'd you get your MBA Oh where'd you
study you know and there's people that
care about that there's other people
that literally do not care at all yeah
and I meet incredibly like from that
perspective I mean incredibly successful
business leaders all the time that don't
have their MBA and went to some State
School in Iowa
I got props the other day from someone
from Iowa that said whenever you think
of that state
yes from Iowa some state school and I
whatever some little Community College
in Nebraska and they go out in world and
dominate so but that's not important we
know that that happens look and there's
people that go to Ivy League schools and
get and they do great too
but what I'm saying is they get in this
little ecosystem where where what
they're actually trying to do is onto
the top of that ecosystem only for the
sake of climbing to the top of that
custom not how it measures into the
greater world what kind of car do you
have
there's an ecosystem you can get wrapped
up in you know I've got of my Porsche is
better than your Porsche right there's
people that are into that and there's
other people that I do not care at all
at all what about our little ecosystems
we're right what did you do has a little
own little ecosystem yep you know what
I'm saying there's a little ecosystem
who's who what the the podcast were old
yeah has an ecosystem so all these
things and those are just things that
that you and I are actually actively in
right we do jujitsu and we have a
podcast so we could jump into like where
you add on the hierarchy of these
ecosystems and again Jordan I get it
we're trying to we're trying to go up
the hierarchy I get it but you have to
be able to put that in check cuz why are
you doing that what is driving you if
it's if what's driving you to ascend
that hierarchy is because it's gonna
make a you better and the people around
you better that's good if you're doing
it for your own ego though that's a
problem mm-hmm that's where it becomes a
problem guess what the jobs or the
companies the industries they get
created they're sort of the jobs that
get created by companies and industries
they have their own little ecosystem
right about I work here I work there I
will I ran this region like you can see
it it's an ecosystem that exists the
SEAL Teams is a freaking ecosystem and
everyone's in there going like okay
where you add on the ecosystem where did
you we know how many deployments if you
don't where did you deploy to what what
schools have you been to there's a
little ecosystem that people are trying
to get out and it's and I get it there's
some positive to that right because
you're trying to do better trying to
work harder that's good then there's
this thing the bar scene you probably
can relate to this better than me
there's an ecosystem of the
yes and who's the owner and who's the
manager and who's the GM and who's the
head door guy yeah and who comes in your
club oh who you gonna let in the club
music scene real estate there's this
ecosystems everywhere and so this is the
point that I guess I'm getting to and
where it ties back into this young
female that asked this question when you
what you have to do is realize that in
most of these cases when you step
outside of that little ecosystem no one
cares about that ecosystem no one cares
mmm no one cares if I was to tell my mom
hey mom I got my black belt in jujitsu
2005 hey mom I got my black belt in
jujitsu she well you know what would you
know what she would say Oh
congratulations know what she's thinking
that I'm in a strip mall doing karate
somewhere you know what I mean yeah
that's what she's thinking
she doesn't care at all she doesn't care
at all mm-hmm your Porsche that you told
me about I can introduce you to many
people that think if you spent more than
five thousand dollars on a vehicle
you're an idiot
never mind a hundred and fifty thousand
dollars in fact if you ever hear me brag
about a vehicle the vehicle that I brag
about probably the most is my 1997 Dodge
Grand Caravan that's the one I brag
about the most mm-hmm so when you step
outside the ecosystem of cool cars
people literally don't do not care the
the music scene oh I know this recording
artist I know oh and I'm going to this
studio it's like no one cares so my
point in saying this is if you find
yourself distraught about your failure
inside some random ecosystem then
remember that if you can detach and you
can step outside that ecosystem you can
realize that that ecosystem
in most cases doesn't even matter at all
hmm it doesn't matter at all